[Music]
ready expanding Career and Technical
Education or CTE is one of today's most
popular education policy issues but
who's been taking these courses CTE
course taking has seen a 30-year decline
business courses are the major driver
why mostly from the drop-in typing
classes since the 80s takeaway business
and course taking is flat but there's
more while traditional vocational
concentrators and subjects like
agriculture and manufacturing have
declined a little New Era concentrators
those in health care or computer science
have increased dramatically these two
groups differ notably on test scores and
college-going traditional concentrators
are below average while New Era
concentrators look average CTE no longer
fits ATS stereotypes concentrators
average outcomes have been rising but is
it because programs are improving or
because they're serving more academic
students for CTE to be successful
leaders must not only ensure programs
are meeting targeted outcomes but also
that they target the students who need
them the most
do you agree our CTE programs reaching
the students that need them the most
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI